okay we have leaked audio of an absolute
madman rant by the president
this happened during a call that Donald
Trump had yesterday with governor's from
around the country the calls were about
the protests the calls were in advance
of Donald Trump going out into the Rose
Garden and saying if you don't scale up
force I will do it for you by sending
the military to your states these are
simply put the rantings of an agitated
lunatic authoritarian who sounds very
desperate who sounds very scared and
realizes he is quickly losing control
that he probably never even really had
let's take a listen to it the context is
totally impotent Trump who was tweeting
insults and threats all weekend from the
White House while adults actually tried
to figure out what to do so first of all
Donald Trump says here I guess that he's
saying that the Minneapolis Police were
are a laughingstock so there is Trump
bragging about when the police became
more militarized they started carving
through crowds of protesters like butter
just disgusting language and for Trump
this is all sport it's all visual it's
what is Fox News showing when Trump
turns on the channel let's continue it
only gets worse from here unfortunately
so here's Donald Trump again making the
case that forces police forces need to
be militarized this is part of the
problem on in the United States
understand that we have a situation here
where we have protests and unrest which
were catalyzed by police using too much
force and killing George Floyd and Trump
is demanding that law enforcement use
even more force it's it could not
possibly be more backwards then here is
Trump again continuing in this leaked
audio of a call with governor's using
the language of the domination of
protesters take a look again the police
police forces must toughen up we'll send
soldiers you have to dominate the
protesters Trump reportedly angry
throughout the entire call Trump said
leaders should be seeking retribution
this is the language of a mob boss this
is not the language of a President of
the United States faced with unrest the
likes of which we've not seen for a long
time
Trump told governor's you don't have to
be too careful in other words don't be
too careful do the opposite of being
careful Trump does not know how to lead
he simply does not have
listen he doesn't have the cognitive
capacity to deal with the complexity of
this situation we have to concede that
and his view is this over-aggressive
view of let's dominate the protesters he
seems afraid not literally of the
protesters but of what this could do to
his presidency but it is just not within
him to lead he doesn't have any tools as
I said yesterday and a lot of people
wrote to me and said David that this
felt like the the the right metaphor or
analogy and I didn't come up with it if
you only have a hammer everything looks
like a nail and that is exactly the
situation we have Trump has very few
tools and he he doesn't have a velvet
glove the way he himself once analogized
he has a couple of different size
hammers and so everything looks like a
nail to him his his tools are shaming
people insulting people making threats
that's what he's doing here even though
it's absolutely the last thing that we
need so we have to realize at this point
many things but I'll focus on two
important realizations that we need to
come to and I know many of you have
probably come to these realizations
already number one we aren't going to
get anything but more of this from
Donald Trump period no matter the
circumstances no matter what is
necessary no matter what it's called for
these are his routines and this is all
he can really do staged photo ops at the
church that we talked about earlier the
military deployments saying governor's
you you better get it together you guys
are jerks or incompetent or whatever
else that's number but that's all we are
going to get from Trump
number two there is a possibility that
Trump actually sees more chaos as good
for him especially if he can frame his
frame it as this is the merely the left
doing bad things which they've started
to do yesterday yesterday I covered live
Trump's press secretary Kaley mcenany
did a press briefing and she must have
talked about anti feh
you know what a dozen times two dozen
times and this is a calculated strategy
they talk about antifa to dismiss and
disqualify the overwhelmingly peaceful
protesters the actual issues that
launched these protests now I don't know
if it will work
this may be a miscalculation by Donald
Trump or it may work if the virus
continues if the chaos continues if the
country continues to see no leadership
from Donald Trump and meanwhile Joe
Biden keeps meeting with protesters and
staking out a position on police
treatment of minorities that addresses
the systemic problems
this doesn't mean Joe Biden is a hero
this means nothing other than on this
issue right now right you can talk about
Biden in 94 right now Joe Biden is
showing more leadership and
understanding of this issue than is
Donald Trump
I don't know that Trump is going to come
away from this unscathed or with a with
an increased approval rating because it
doesn't look like he's doing anything
right now there's a new national poll
out from NBC from ABC from over the
weekend which has Joe Biden at plus 10
points nationally against Donald Trump
this is an unconscionable number this is
on the high end polls are generally
showing Biden leading by between 4 and
11 nationally so certainly 10 is on the
high end but what is it that will come
from what Trump is doing that will close
the gap with Biden whether you believe
the gap is four or ten or seven what is
it that Trump is doing that will close
the gap it's hard to imagine his
supporters will be with him no matter
what but consider the backwards nature
of Trump's reaction and this is what I
keep going back to the protests were
started by the brutal handling of a
black man by Minnesota police so what
does Trump do he says you governors need
to be more aggressive and I will send
federal military to be more aggressive
if you don't do it I don't know that
this will work I hope that it doesn't
work because it's absolutely horrifying
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always struggling
to find the time check out one of my
all-time favorite apps called blink its
blink Isleta consume an entire book on
your way home from work
they take thousands of popular
non-fiction books condense each one into
text or audio that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the
important core ideas and information
from that book it's perfect if you don't
have enough time to do all the reading
you want to do or if you just want to
sample a book before you buy the entire
thing I recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great Stephen
Hawking this is a book that I have been
aware of for so long and other things
got in the way and it was fantastic to
check it out on blinkin
blink east has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
is comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video